during an accident we saved you and now  you save others you have a most  sophisticated weapon find the terrorists  what are you we are the same did they  tell you home and he died to create us  she knows I order you determinate they  created me that they cannot control me  ghost in the shell I'm watching you you  have to remember off the landowner  there wasn't human he's a known  terrorist and he killed again  I didn't just kill them I hacked into  their life  is everywhere no I will find him and I  will kill him you never talk about your  past don't remember the fragment there  was an attack  you were dying we saved you and now you  save others  everything they told you what a lie you  had a family remember that  but I  beauty  what do you want for me  they did not save your life they stole  it  how many were there before me she was  supposed to have a Creamery  i order you to terminate  make up  they created me but they cannot control  me  you  you